have you heard of peter gray's
unschooling
i have but i'm blanking can you
essentially so it's not like tear down
the schools but what i'm saying is that
the
that kids is taking an evolutionary
psychological approach to
learning that kids learn best in mixed
age groups and one of the reasons is
that there's no bullying because you're
eight
you're not going to compete with a 16
year old and you're not vice versa
and then 16 year old is not going to
compete with a 24 year old and he takes
this from
observing tribes that don't have schools
and the kids just learn automatically
because play is so important and when
they're playing they just
they happen to learn and it's
spontaneous and you allow the kid to
follow their own interests and you
encourage it yeah that of imposing one
yeah so i think this this whole movement
um of inquiry-based learning is
very very interesting but also um i
think we have to be a little careful
with it
uh i i'm i'm definitely
for um kids being able to like figure
out what they like
themselves and just like go down that
rabbit hole like that's you know a big
part of like
my education was that um but
i think on the other hand like letting
kids have completely free reign
um i mean there has been some research
about this like
it just doesn't work as well if you have
like no sort of
um either discipline or uh like guidance
about where to go because you know
you're not going to expect a child
playing on their own
to rediscover mutants laws like that's
just not
possible um but on the other hand if you
had like a a
supervising figure who was there to like
encourage
uh the you know the interests as they as
they develop
and sees that you know this person's
interested in how things work and it's
like oh have you read
these interesting books like that could
potentially work i think that
um to make that work uh we need to put
like a lot
more thought into just how like we can
guide
that experience without um you know
fully
uh determining what the kid is going to
do ourselves